[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation your host on Sakia and we
have an epic guest that is returning for
his second show with us David Savage
hello my friends they keep her going
back on the show good to be back this is
the first time I've been on something
twice yeah it's a milestone yes you must
have enjoyed our first time together I
did that's what I figured out from this
invitation yes yes there it's like I'm
in San Francisco doing these events and
I saw it in his email blast and I was
like come do another show with us happy
to be here yes and it was episode 114
for those that wants to go back the
links in the bio Dave this episode is
called the empath returns because that
episode is called the empath and an
empath means that you feel other
people's feelings that's how I use the
word yes yes and I would agree that that
is a really great way great definition
and you've been up to some good moves so
you got some links in the bio as well to
check out but you have now so besides
doing your live workshops these events
that you perform at actually doing live
demonstrations where you tap into how
someone else is feeling now there's a
kick starter going on for a play that
you're doing in New York you got it
which is exciting and you have what's
your friend's name that's the director
Katie Davis Katie Davis cool and it's
like on 36th Street right it is a
beautiful theater called theatre lab on
36th between 8th and 9th right around
there in Ronnie won't pull the NDI up
and we have a nice we have a weave we
have your Kickstarter up here but
specifically the image there that's it
right there
yeah that's the beautiful location I
love it yeah so in April I
and I did three workshop performances of
this play which I'm calling empath to
test it out get feedback see how it went
and we sold out this was one of the
three shows we sold out all three
performances people really liked it and
they also gave us some really good
feedback that we're integrating now and
the theater was happy with it and they
invited us back but we need some some
help making it as a production as big
and beautiful as it wants to be and
$8,000 is such a small goal for play you
know this is it is a small goal but it
will be achieved we got 21 days to go
okay we'll be making a donation later
today yes and it's just the order of the
way yeah yeah the small donations are
what you know what gets the avalanche
effect only people sharing it on social
media that kind of stuff hopefully we
can help David out here with the program
and alright so this is going on also the
live workshops are still happening at
the same time you're just did
consciousness acting here yeah I did
conscious I did an event with
consciousness hacking just last night
Mikey Segal asked me to do it and I had
a blast of maybe 80 people there nice
and I taught people who didn't even know
such a phenomenon existed that it was
possible to feel other people's feelings
or that we are already often feeling
other people's feelings yeah and we
experimented with that and then I showed
them how I do it so here's the advanced
version for you to wonder at but don't
think it's inaccessible to you it's
totally accessible to you it's just a
process and here's step 1 or step 2
along that along that process that was
that that was the workshop yesterday and
then on Saturday this coming Saturday
I'm doing an event called ask p.m. path
where I'll be fielding questions from
whoever wants to ask me something in a
in a you know my friend Rachel's home
and we only have a few tickets left but
if you're watching this and you want to
ask me whatever you want come to ask the
empath you can find it on my website
I've had the NYC and NYC in this one
that I went to last time yeah yeah
Rachel Rachel yeah yeah she has a
beautiful home in Noe Valley and hosted
like what 30 40 people last time and it
was super fun I met a lot of really cool
people there too yeah and then but my
primary focus is you're watching the
Kickstarter for it my primary focus is
this is this play after these events I'm
doing one or two small things in New
York but I'm doing them largely to
promote this play to raise money for it
and then to get butts in the seats yep
starting on November 29th and this is
the thing I am most excited about and is
where I'm putting the bulk of my energy
through this year November 29th until
when is it gonna rot
December 9th this is a shoe two weeks in
a row four performances each week Wow
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday two
weeks in a row awesome starting this
November 29th awesome that'll be really
fun and then posting that and filming
that posting it are you gonna take
different audience members in yes which
so every show will be different every
show will be different all eight shows
will be different I love that it's two
pieces to the show
the first is me telling not telling in
acting and showing my story of who I was
before this all fell on me and how it
all fell on me and how I went with it
fought it went with it and accepted it
and then at the end of the show I will
pull people from the audience and invite
them to sit in front of me and do
readings with them and then maybe open
it up even beyond whoever sits with me
into some kind of group feeling which
all improvised on the spot so it's a
combination of storytelling
improvisational empathic readings yes in
a genre of theater I feel like Katie and
I are creating you are at immersive
interactive theater psychic intuitive
theater with the conventional elements
so you can just if you just like
watching a play where a story happens
you will be satisfied yeah and if you
like watching stuff or you don't know
what's gonna happen next and this is
really weird and it's gonna get awkward
you will be satisfied and if you're
intrigued that the combination of the
two you will really enjoy yourself and I
am intrigued with the combination of the
two I love that I am too psychic
intuitive so I want to I want to talk
about this because I think I think this
is a really good starting point for what
our discussion is where it's gonna go so
like you said that just happened at
consciousness hacking there was a
realization from some people that was
like not only can people go to the
depths of feeling what someone else is
feeling at this crazy level that you do
but then there's also the very like
intro level 101 which is like when
someone is yelling what do I feel when
they're yelling hmm so that's like kind
of like 101 maybe or when someone is
laughing uncontrollably what do I feel
yeah maybe that's 102 101 is just B what
am I feeling right now period yeah yeah
yeah and I think most people would say
what am I feeling right now the answer
most people would give if asked on the
spot is either I don't know how I'm
feeling right now
or a story they have in their head about
how they're feeling right now which may
or may not reflect what they're actually
feeling mm-hmm so I'm feeling good
says the person who wants to be feeling
good but in actuality I'm feeling good
is covering an anxiety that you can see
right there they're not actually feeling
good they're feeling anxious or tense or
if you wanted to get more specific
they're feeling a
a feeling of being pulled tight from
inside behind their chest and that's how
they're feeling when they say I'm
feeling good those are common those are
common responses yeah and that is one oh
one is so I like how we're laying this
out and this is Ron this is where I
would love to get used to using a
whiteboard on the show somehow so we
could start showing things on a screen
or maybe like we can just start live
illustrating with like a tablet or
something we'll give you it in the air
and then yeah later
yeah yeah so okay so on one side we have
101 it's just being able to tune into
our own feelings in the moment feel how
we feel to the most accurate levels that
we can or as well that would be 102
accuracy almost just like okay I don't
want to get people that high standard
just literally how am I feeling right
now close your eyes and then however
you're feeling at that moment you don't
need words for it just that
physiological experience you're having
in your body at that moment is 101 and
even if the answer that question is I
have no idea how I'm feeling I feel
nothing then that void or that blankness
is the feeling you're feeling we accept
that you have now past class 101 because
you've closed your eyes tuned and felt
nothing and acknowledged it okay so it's
just a first physiological of feeling
without putting words on it
oh yes ii o 1 1 o 1 o 2 is getting more
accurate temperature should we should we
take it a step at a time you want to
keep going fast if we go faster gonna
lose lose some stuff if it go slow
let's go slow it's gonna this is excited
dragged out a little bit let's go slow
with a kick and then so that we can get
to these other pressing issues okay okay
so 102 is is tapping into the
physiological feeling and then maybe
being able to get more and more accurate
yes
level of nuance so 102 we don't settle
for I feel nothing anymore we patiently
await for an actual experience to arise
and we start
the qualities of that experience we're
still not putting words on it or if we
are putting words on it we're saying
words like tingling pressure temperature
flow urge impulse pulsation the subtle
experiences of being in one's own body
those are just my words there are a
billion better ones so now we're I'm
feeling the way my voice subtly echos
inside my chest what is that little
fluctuation I'm feeling how my voice
comes out through my throat out into the
air that has a vibration I can feel it
there's a tingling under my nose there's
a little bit of pressure in my chest you
know and I could go on and on it
infinitum now we're at 102 where I'm
actually having subtle experiences in my
body that I'm able to I like that take a
mental note of and I wonder if y know if
that might be one of three because 102
might be being able to see like when
someone else is giggling with joy or
when they're super angry and then being
like what is that energy doing to me
yeah I'd be like one oh I think that's
one a hole that's maybe we can start
with putting that in anything that's
past maybe that's two maybe now we're
out we're out of the out of the one out
of the ones into the intermediate so 201
is then being able to take the first
bits of energy from other people - oh
one would be noticing shifts in your
physiology based on internal external
experiences one of the primary external
experiences is going to shift your
physiology is going to be other people
but you could also notice a shift in
your physiology as you step into a room
or you walk outside or oh how is that
changing me internally let's give an
example quick it's like when you walk
into
a rambunctious bar and that's just like
music is playing people are talking
there's a thousand voices going on and
then the other one is when you just walk
through the park and there's just birds
chirping and there's trees and there's
animals and it's all you hear is that
those are great so the first one a lot
of people won't not all people but a lot
of people walking into that bar will
feel something in them clenched up I'll
be one of them some of the people will
be opened up so by definition your
physiological experience gonna be
different than anybody else's and that's
cool we're talking about the specificity
of your experience but most people
walking in out of nowhere into a loud
intense bar experience will clench up
something in them retreats even if
they're not conscious of it and then
most people walking through a park
something in them including me loosens
there's a spaciousness this is not
conceptual spaciousness this is actual
feeling of one's aura expanding that's
real so now I'm feeling it I can imagine
it too calling in the idea encourages
the experience to snow okay and now
maybe we can get to one of - OH - OH -
OH - - OH - where Oh
being around you shifts me in some way -
OH - gets complicated because am i
shifting because something in you
triggers something in me not necessarily
in a negative sense I like you I'm drawn
to you I'm curious trigger some kind of
curiosity desire to interact that has a
physiological component I'm leaning in
maybe or am i affected by something
about you that isn't necessarily
triggering in me an emotional reaction
but is your energy itself is permeating
through me and now I'm feeling you and
I'm we're we're syncing up on some level
where your energy is meeting my energy
I'm taking on some of your energy and
that's a different kind of shift and
that's the place where I've been carving
out a little bit of a home in the
cultural landscape saying well that
moment where somebody else's
emotionality physiology vibration energy
whatever language you want
put on it affects me in subtle ways that
are meaningful and demonstrate that we
are all interconnected woven together
through these fields okay let's throw
let's throw this on you'll see what I've
been doing Ron's gonna throw it on the
screen
oh wow okay okay so we have feeling our
own physiology feeling our own
physiology with more accuracy yes
and then jewel I would say with subtlety
with subtlety yeah and then noticing
shifts based on changes that are in the
external world
shifts in our physiology yeah I mean
yeah inner experience probably could go
beyond physiology into oh when I go into
a park I have these kinds of thoughts I
wouldn't call that necessarily
physiology that's probably that's just
as valid but physiology is a good word
to the example given would be feeling
calmer how in a park
I feel walking into a bar versus walking
into a park that's great okay making it
up as we go yeah we should sell the
class this this class classes on how to
feel which is kind of cool if you think
about it I mean that's what we're
learning all the time but nobody ever
taught us so maybe it's cool to make it
into a class let's get let's get the
sales force as a sponsor for this class
Marc Benioff has been very generous with
his partnerships and sponsorships anyone
out there that's watching from
Salesforce I think there's you know you
think about how much feeling is our
whole experience and how little we think
about it it's kind of amazing and then
we think about thinking all the time all
the time there how much thought is given
to thought a lot more than how much
thought or attention is given to feeling
even though feeling is our primary mode
of experiencing the world yeah yeah
that's right that's right
so 202 would be I think that might have
to be because of the amount of logic
that we have to use to maneuver the
world we're born into the societal
pressures that cause us to need to use
logic more whereas if we were enabled as
a child to use more of our feeling or
intuition and have society that enabled
the use of that more then that's how we
could that's how that's gonna be talked
about in this transition period we've
got we got we got um we got thrown off
course at some point because we got hurt
and then instead of dealing with the
hurt we found that there was a way to
simultaneously avoid feeling hurt and
things that looked productive yeah and
those two tendencies colluded to create
all the machinery of modern life and now
maybe we're starting or those of us who
are in this Western modern paradigm are
starting to realize oops maybe we can go
back to the to the source the feeling
space and then eventually into class 202
which is what I've been teaching which
is how we are shifted by other people
how our experience is shifted by other
people
interesting okay so how our experience
is shifted by other people so this can
be maybe like example given how you feel
when someone is laughing or angry great
okay and then now is there a 300 what
would be like 301 now we go we leave the
realm of passively noticing our own
experience and in class 3 we start
playing with it deliberately so how to
deliberately open ourselves up to these
kinds of experiences safely or how to
deal with experiences that we've had
that we don't want to have in the future
how to work with this stability
deliberately yeah how to work with this
ability deliberately deliberately and
safely open ourselves up to these
experiences yes and yeah work with this
ability yep that's yeah people often
want to skip to class 301 yeah
me too everyone wants to know how to do
something but the building blocks are
always crucial everything before then so
just go on to the core and start
shooting three-pointers you don't just
go and start closing million-dollar
deals you got to close those ten dollar
deals yeah so literally going how am I
feeling right now
and even if the answer is I have no idea
literally but I've tried to feel
something you've now passed class 101
and you we can build from there into oh
wow I'm deliberately opening myself up
to this person's energy I'm
understanding how it affects me and then
maybe in class 302 I'm using what I'm
getting to help others consciously we're
doing it all the time unconsciously but
now we can start doing it consciously
yeah okay so so 302 once you start
deliberately and safely working with the
ability then you start feeling how to
help yep this young lady okay so then
this would also be maybe
mm-hmm this is a big a big part of this
in my opinion at least from the very
small amount of intuitive practice that
I've had with this is that I it's really
important for me to know when I am doing
a process that is energetically
exhausting for me taking on someone
else's experience with trauma or taking
on their their they need to path the
path of growth for them the integration
of the trauma and the growth because
that mean that requires me to hold space
and all that so so again when you're
working with this process it's probably
one of the most important things to
understand how you're feeling throughout
it because it can be extremely
exhausting important thing to understand
how you yourself are feeling is the is
the foundation of I want to say it's the
foundation of all growth it doesn't mean
you have to be conscious of it all the
time I don't want to put that pressure
on people but if there's another way to
grow into who you really are
that doesn't involve feeling what you're
actually feeling I don't know it's that
that that that's my that's the
limitation of my own worldview or either
that or I'm just right and there is
there is this pathway that's open to all
of us that few of us take where we grow
through our own experience and much of
our own experiences is is the felt sense
but we can broaden that it's not just
what you're feeling can also be what
you're hearing and seeing and what's
coming through you but having a
reference point for how everything
that's showing up feels in your body
feels so crucial yeah yeah having that
reference point and that's the reference
point is 101 and then one or two
developing outlet and then we can we can
package this probably away now but it's
just yeah it's quite it's quite cool we
finally were able to illustrate
something on
a spectrum but on a development spectrum
so if you feel your own with subtlety
and then you notice your shifts based on
external world and then you you notice
the shifts from other people and then
you deliberately and safely work with it
and then I wrote helping other people
with the ability like holy crap it
sounds great and then if we wanted to go
to four 402 we never got working with
non-human entities yeah entities subtler
energies other layers of information
subtler energies yeah
and then I mean the dead-honest I mean
this stuff that's out there we might not
necessarily believe in but that seems to
show up regularly to people who seem to
have a capacity for it yeah a lot of
this and actually this is part of what
initially got needed the spectrum was
just the ability to if what if we
believe that everything is connected if
we believe that the butterfly effect
exists if we believe that there is all
fibers are connected of every atom of
every molecule of every Planck length
that then there is some sort of ability
then to go from my toroidal form of
energy into your toroidal form of energy
through this interconnected web totally
feeling not only your soul at this
moment but feeling feeling across the
earth to how China currently feels I
think this is very possible feeling how
a dolphin currently feels swimming
through that gorgeous ocean jumping
through the and enjoying that feeling
how that tree that's been alive for
thousands of years feels as it's
continuing to nourish that environment
get those resources from the soil and
the resources from the sunlight totally
how about how the dolphin feels when
they're being slaughtered in that
Japanese massacre every year do we can
we touch on that or we can bring
awareness to that you just have a water
yeah there's a pants water the pain of
the dolphin being slaughtered is now
present in this space
yeah the Taiji dolphin drivelines
yeah yeah just just for just for a
moment because I'm not we don't know we
don't know how many people are yeah are
aware of this but government quota
allows over two thousand to be
slaughtered or captured
annually 22 thousand are killed so so
why money why money go ahead show the
picture context obviously I would rather
not look at a picture let's not do it on
David Stream but but we just brought
awareness to it but that's that's yeah
that was our I'm sorry Dave okay my role
is devil's advocate I appreciate you're
all okay so that was expressing my
preference yes yes that was okay that
was 401 and then we can just end there
and then we'll for 402 as something to
do with the way we engage with these
entities may be maximized and 402 would
be something like travel
interdimensional travel or something
like that
we've now let gone beyond my paygrade a
little bit I'll have flashes of this
totally yeah all right beautiful good
job team we've nice we'll put this in
the bio after the show as well I'm glad
you guys got a chance to take a look at
it and I'm glad we got to make this we
will be doing this more often on the
show integrating a note and then writing
in it if we have good thoughts to
integrate okay so back to the the
Kickstarter page here we go maybe we can
we can yes tie a link tie make a link
between what we just said and
my own story yeah which is that I went
through my own much less linear process
to go from this stuff whatever this
stuff is isn't real there's no
underlying meaning to things information
travels the way we expect if you're
making other claims you're nuts or
you're fraud to not just learning to
accept that some of these things are
real but actually realizing that I'm
here as a vehicle for them yes and then
starting to do this work which was and
remains still a little bit embarrassing
to me yes
cuts across some of my own narratives of
self stumbling and bumbling my way from
well-educated typical Jewish skeptical
type grew up in LA upper-middle class
slightly academic backgrounds to
somebody who does intuitive readings for
a living and teaches people about subtle
realms so that's it that was a journey
and that's a journey that my play will
take you on
yes good and and it's it's just for me
personally I find I get more joy out of
bringing people along for the ride from
I don't believe any of the stuff - hmm
that's interesting yeah yeah then I do
bringing people from I'm having all
these experiences that are real but I
don't know what to do about them - I
feel now more grounded in that I do a
lot of that second kind of work all the
time and I'm happy to do it but where my
heart is is come on guys let's go yeah
it's time let's let's wake up to these
possibilities magic is real look I'm
here let's do it and that's what the
play is about I'm really happy that you
made the distinction there between
people that just completely discredit
anything that doesn't have data that's
subjective
and versus people that are getting so
much of that data that they can't
organize it and figure the ground
themselves with it but I've really liked
that I
also have really enjoy for me a lot of
it is like when someone goes I don't
care at all about biology and then I'm
like it's the code of life yeah and then
and then they're like what do you and
then they're so it's great yeah we have
the same we have the same purpose in
some sense we're onboarding people or
we're outreach for another way of
looking at things yes that's where my
heart is I want to be I want to be a
billboard for another way of doing
things and I also want to make
billboards for other ways of doing
things in the literal sense yeah but I
myself am working to be an emissary a
brand ambassador for this other world
that we have a felt sense of
occasionally spy out there and the
distance dream about I want to say hey
it's already kind of here a little bit
can you see it
and then when Ron says but what about
the dying dolphin I'm like I let's
integrate that that's part of this world
too I don't want to push anything aside
that's how we that's how we fall down by
pushing aside let's let's integrate as
well yeah and have open discourse about
moving away from practices that we find
to be causing suffering on the planet or
if we can do even better bringing as
much compassion and love to the causes
of those sufferings or those people
enacting that cycle so that it just
stops on its own instead of blaming them
for their behaviors what is the
compulsion to Massacre dolphins if we
truly understood that we could heal it
very easily but if we say well the
problem is that they're killing the
dolphins then we're like okay then we
have to stop them from killing the
dolphins but then they go and kill the
seals the next day it's just yeah it's
forwards it's the process of the
underlying mechanism roots
yeah roots yeah and allowing with as
much compassion as we can muster or
those of us who have that compassion to
show up for it for the for the blockages
to this more beautiful world to quote
to quote a writer I deeply admire
Charles Eisenstein the more beautiful
world our hearts know as possible that
we are all either consciously or
unconsciously working toward even as we
fight it yep let's let's discuss this
this came up in our last episode
together and you highlighted it and I've
loved watching it several times now the
society has evolved to a point of a
masculine energetic grip and there is a
transitionary process of the feminine
energy that is that is the masculine
grip is that feminine energies coming in
the masculine grip is slowly unraveling
enough to where the feminine grip can
also come and be present right that at
the same time as harmony you really like
that harmony idea I like a mess I think
I think I think the city of balance or
harmony is allows it to be safe for
those of us who feel a need to still
control things enough so we're like okay
we're going to find this place where I'm
still represented in my need and desire
to control things with information and
thought and clarity I'll still be safe
there and there'll be space for this
other thing I don't fully understand but
I know it's kind of an equal partner
sort of yeah we'll figure it out
together it's a very comforting story
but I don't think it's the real one when
you love this mess tell us yeah I love
the mess I think the chem mess in
harmony lived together
no do you say we do all right out yeah
yeah yeah
no but a mess is necessary for eventual
establishing of harmony yeah I think yes
so it's it's not so it's messy but then
it harmonizes it's not up its we can
make this a little bit more concrete
let's say you run some kind of
organization that's extremely
data-driven and hyper-rational and you
don't believe as I've heard in so many
boardrooms if we don't measure it it
doesn't count this is your this is your
principle we don't measure it it doesn't
count if we can't put a number to it it
doesn't matter this is the operating
system but this is the operating system
of most most organizations in the world
today it's good but it's also like can
be dangerous in many ways it's like
someone comes in with an emotion or a
feeling it's like yo we can't measure
that right yeah or they say okay if
you're gonna bring something other than
what we can measure into this space
because we have some sense we're feeling
enough pressure to care about oh
meditation even if we can't prove that
it's worth something we're gonna let
everyone meditate for 10 minutes a day
because it's trendy and we want to be
seen as cool even though we can't
measure the value of cool we're a little
afraid of being seen as uncool so we're
gonna do it but we're gonna need you to
prove the value of this meditation to
the bottom line Lucifer why do they make
all these people who are bringing
something new and subjugate themselves
to the tyranny of what can be measured
okay let's say you bring in a violinist
on Friday when everybody yeah yeah you
know or do you need to quantify that
with the bottom line or do you just
intuitively know that somebody that's
playing the violin or the Trump's they
think about what happens if here's what
I'm saying that this this harmony you're
thinking about is is is a comforting
illusion because when you start to go
open up to this violinist you bring in
this violinist and there's an energy
that shifts and suddenly what happens if
people are really open to the
transformative power of art is they
start to prioritize things that can't be
measured more it's not that you start
measuring those things that
be measured that's holding on you start
shifting and you go wait wait wait a
second my heart is opening to this music
when I go back to my cubicle and I
figure out how to extract more money
from customers my heart is closing or
provide more value to customers because
it doesn't have to be that mate it
doesn't have to be here right that's my
bias even but I'm providing more value
I'm at a distance like theirs when you
start to let in that that Amorphis stuff
that is the beauty of life as we all
experience it it wants to take over
because we want to live that way we want
to live in connection in love in joy and
excitement not a Cuba we don't want to
live we just don't want to live as
slaves to numbers we just don't want to
do it that's what a heist job is for
maybe that's what a eyes job is for yeah
maybe that's what they have Travis for
so that's it so it just gets messy like
yes there is a balance to be had but the
balance is in comes after we prioritize
this objective comes after we prioritize
what wants to happen what our hearts are
longing for so I used to go crazy
because I would go into any kind of
meeting and you say this is the
underlying truth that wants to be known
or seen and I felt deeply connected to
something and they would say prove it
and then you go through this song and
dance to prove it and you felt like in
the proving of it you were killing it
this is true of every every nonprofit
deals with this problem every nonprofit
that's motivated from the heart it's
like oh we're doing this amazing thing
we know it and our bones are so drawn to
it and then they go to a funder and the
funder sits back and says can you prove
to me the ROI can you prove to me the
value and then the then that then the
nonprofit has to go through this whole
long song and dance about the underlying
value that can be reduced to numbers and
then deliver it on a platform to this
funder who then says oh this makes a lot
of sense but we know in the process that
something is just
dying the life of the project has been
killed through this process and it's
rare is the person running that
nonprofit who can hold both the
underlying meaning of what they're doing
and tell the BS story about its
measurable value to people who are gonna
finance it in his or her mind Hart at
the same time so usually there's this
split
yes you're illustrating something very
important but I also want to see if it
can if it can actually harmonize through
the mess
so in this exact depiction that you've
Illustrated we could have a person that
is roaring with their heart and their
soul on a nonprofit project meanwhile at
the same time there is AI or engineers
that are working with the actual data
that exists from the value that they are
providing other people and they're just
simply measuring it and seeing what
methods of disseminating the information
can maximize the value so anyway I agree
it exists of what these what's the it's
a I guess the difference is whether
you're oriented around the goal which is
almost inevitably going to be
reductionist or whether you're oriented
around a process which is open so if
you're already you're like I want to go
open - Thank You Ronnie for the timer
let's okay let's jump into a couple
other things that we wanted to talk
sounds good I think this has been
something that we've talked about on the
show quite a bit about you know we've
had Rock Rasim on the show talking about
5mu DMT we've had Michael Pollan talking
about psychedelics a great how to change
your mind so what does psychedelics have
to do with empathy everything
well these are like two of my greatest
favorite themes crossing so I could go
on forever but let me see if I can
summarize psychedelics show us that we
are interconnected they don't just show
us conceptually they give us the
experience of that sense of
interconnectedness sometimes they give
us the experience
a-five Mao DMT does of they're not even
being an I to be interconnected we are
nothing but the interconnectivity and
empathy is nothing more than the
recognition that there's not a
meaningful separation between you and me
yeah yeah there you have it yeah that
was boiled down quite well so all right
let's let's let's keep unpacking this
intersection because there's there's so
much more nuance to it so let's talk
about how we have an event coming up
with psychedelics seminars on micro
dosing with il Waldman and Jim Fadiman
tickets are still available go to
simulation series calm for those tickets
October 22nd so let's talk about how
those small sort of micro doses into
psychedelics begin the process of
enabling 101 102 201 202 to slowly
amplify to make it easier to open up our
truth is I know very little about micro
dosing my approach my approach has been
has been macro dosing I think there's
probably a lot of people who are micro
dosing because they want to open
themselves up and are afraid to quote
unquote go for it and if micro dosing
makes you feel safe and secure on your
journey wonderful but the truth is when
I've micro dosed
I get this little feeling of like yeah
this is a nice little snack it take me
there
I tend to agree that's not to disparage
micro dosers I tend to agree with you
but but basically a lot of this
conversation on micro dosing is really
about the power of psychedelics with a
little on rap for people too afraid to
go into them fully and I appreciate your
fear and your fear might be very well
placed maybe micro dosing is a great on
ramp
however I'm a big fan of of going for it
there's a sign yes
safety and security needs to be there
the proper and fine let's all say that
yeah I mean yeah that's actually truly
important
David you seem like somebody that's had
phenomenal psychedelic experiences and I
have as well and the thing about our
experiences is that they're going to be
completely snowflake in terms of
difference from others and so somebody
else doesn't have necessarily the yeah
but you know I'll tell you what what
what great looks
I agree like please everyone be careful
with psychedelics it really matters so
you're taking one with it really matters
where you're taking them it really
matters the quality but my god be
careful with Zoloft and Prozac and
lithium and valium and methadone and all
of these poisons and some of them are
not poison some of them are real
lifesavers I don't mean to disparage
people taking taking outside depressants
if it's if it's really helping you okay
get a different output pharmaceutical
and caffeine and all of these things
that change our nervous system in ways
we don't fully understand that we're not
being told to be careful about and
things that open us wide open to the
magical possibilities of the universe we
have to do you know tap-dance around it
and be like oh it's going to be fun it's
good it's just it's just
MDMA you need a safe environment and
this and that it's like meanwhile people
drink and drive like it's nothing yeah
and
you know so I'm like hey how about we
put some of those seatbelts on around
all the stuff we do that's toxic and
dangerous in day to day life and loosen
this narrative around the importance of
being careful in a place that is
fundamentally beautiful and heart
affirming and infinite that was so well
said I love it I love it get more people
aware about the consequences of alcohol
and the caffeine and the tobacco and the
other pharmaceutical addictions and then
loosen up the restraints a bit on the
psychedelics but also be careful okay
good stuff I wanted to see what you
would say because you know you do blast
off in psychedelic world me too
let's just at least touch on what
exactly that does to one's ability
because you did mention you gave these
examples and they were really good about
the intersection of it's like nukes but
let's let's Pierce this the way that
let's just give an example especially
with you when you're sitting here across
from somebody and you're feeling what
they're feeling
what has psychedelics done to get you
closer into feeling what they're feeling
ayahuasca was huge for me
ayahuasca taught me that I was carrying
other people's feelings in my body and
showed me how to release them whoa
ayahuasca took me on the journey from
hey a lot of what is quote-unquote wrong
with you or a lot of what's holding you
back isn't even yours I'm gonna show
that to you and then I'm gonna give you
these tools to let go of that stuff and
then once I'd done that or a lot of that
then when I was sitting across from
someone even socially I was so much more
sensitive to what my experience was of
their experience and because I was
independent of all these psychedelics
relatively articulate I would be able to
put words to it and then from that this
this career is sort of taken off started
to take off on the run way of taking off
who knows
interesting so ayahuasca was the big one
opener and then that had that helped you
understand what with
you was holding you back that you were
carrying that wasn't even yours yeah and
then you kind of were able to you know
package that'll integrate it package it
away very concretely like III talked
about this in my play show this in the
play so ayahuasca the first time I did
ayahuasca I wanted like great wisdom to
come down yeah show me what I need to
know and the ayahuasca didn't have much
wisdom for me in the conventional sense
but it took me into my body and I was
tensing and releasing and tensing and
releasing and writhing and on the floor
and what it was showing me was that I
was carrying all this stuff in my body
that needed just to be physically
released and what I thought was a
conceptual issue was actually in my
muscles and and then it kept showing me
images of other people whether it was
somebody very close to me or just some
guy I met at a coffee shop that I had
absorbed their energy and it showed me
how to release that I felt so much
lighter after that and from that place
of lightness I've been able to do this
work yes Wow
okay just I'm feeling you described this
and I'm feeling you advanced level up by
iOS has leveled me up
and I wonder I wonder how else you know
we gave this 101 to 402 the thing that
we made and it's just it's cool that
there are these processes that we can
help disseminate and teach and
psychedelics that have been around for
thousands of years this practice of
empathy that's been around since we
evolved since as we've been involving
that just in getting more into our
bodies are more into feeling and energy
and emotion so okay let's let's talk
about this on the way out just because
you brought this up I thought it was
really important the sort of societal
pressures that we face that prevent us
from self actualization there's these
societal pressures of this is what you
should be this is what how you should
act this is all of these different
should should
these are all these ideal scenarios that
you could potentially be and whatnot
and then there is the self that's having
its own experience that wants to heal
that wants to integrate its trauma that
wants to explore its own self path so
teach us about this most beautifully
said you did a great job summarizing it
we were talking about is what is it the
core of everything I'm talking about
what I deeply believe and what I'm
working to bring out into this world
along with many other people is the idea
that we all have within us this
fundamental self that's different person
to person you are not the same as me we
are different and my job or purpose is
to allow that essential me out into its
full expression here on this planet and
there are two ways to go about doing
that one is let's call it healing which
is working through whatever is blocking
the expression of that self whether
that's the stuff in the past or dynamics
in the present that could be clarified
and the other is through following one's
bliss going where one is excited to go
seeing what's happening and whoa cool
and going there through these two
parallel processes some underlying
deeper self naturally emerges this is
the meta-narrative underneath all of my
work and I recognize that this narrative
is antithetical to our cultural
narrative so our cultural narrative is
constantly telling us that there is an
ideal that we should strive for or maybe
different sets of ideals for a man the
ideal is a successful wealthy father
with who cares about a lot of people
that's sort of like the apex
hypothetically women are taught all
sorts of different narratives from being
a sexy 20 year old to being a mother in
her 30s to being this nurturing loving
person these are all these different
ideals that we get saddled with that
operate independent of who we as
individuals really are yes and I want a
world where we are encouraged where the
culture is pushing us or supporting us
to unfold who we are instead of
constantly selling us these ideals that
tell us we're falling short yeah yeah
some aspects to the culture that we live
in or yes they're really heavy pressures
in a lot of ways and they they actually
vector us away from that soul blueprint
that we have there are other ones that
are interesting that are you know it's
like find meaning in life by taking on
responsibilities and and also make some
sort of impact make the world better
than when you arrived in it and so maybe
there are other ones like that that are
those cultural pressures that I'm like
good like those are cool and I think
they match with almost everyone's soul
blueprint we they I mean I don't know I
went to I remember going to do the fancy
high school and there was all this
pressure around community service you
got to do your community service 16
hours of community service and people
would just go through the motions of
doing community service because it
didn't feel true to them and I'm not
sure that making peanut butter
sandwiches for homeless people thinking
it was stupid did anything for anybody
there's a variety of ways to perform
community service but even that really
in a way it's to play so you know like
the service to the community is a
natural the desire to do it happens
naturally if we feel resourced and full
whereas if we're doing it because
our ego says a good person does it or
we're doing it because there's a
pressure to do it and we should be
ashamed if we don't care about other
people that underlying resistance or
resentment will find its expression in
other ways and I'm not sure ultimately
it's a more service than for that person
who says you know what I don't give a
damn about other people I just care
about me there's a lot of shame for
somebody who who feels that way but I
would rather a world where they can say
that and own that then a world where
they have to hide that because if they
can say that I own that we can work with
that but if they have if they get to
hide that because they make
contributions to charity then we're all
living in delusional land let's give
another example that could be maybe
potentially be more awakening on the on
the way out just this example of if the
opportunity the resource the tool is
available to go and see what the lowest
socioeconomic status lives like and be
able to go and serve them for a period
of a day or however long you choose to
do that then there's another resource or
tool which is the ability to go and get
a tour of a waste facility to be able to
see how garbage and recycling and
composting or septic systems or
slaughterhouses
or these different systems how they
actually from go for a day just for the
tools to be made available so that
people can choose to go and explore them
that way we can have a more objective
sort of Reason driven ethics driven
morals driven way of driving
civilization for it because these tools
are made available just for people to be
able to choose not that everybody needs
to be pressured but just so that they
are available to choose well I think we
can we can have just to allow for a
little disagreement in worldviews I
probably want the world you're
envisioning that you believe these
things will will move people toward I
don't believe that that process you're
describing go check this out go check
that out it is why it's inclined yeah so
so then the underlying thing that I'm
interested in is what is your actual
experience of your life as
right now and where is that pulling you
toward honestly and if you're lost and
you have no idea can you own being lost
can you own that you have no idea and
see what wants to emerge through that
confusion and if you do have this
impulse you're like I'm drawn to the
soil I'm drawn to the water I'm drawn to
the trees I'm drawn well then by all
means please God follow it yes but don't
follow it because you feel like a good
person would be would be drawn there
follow it because you are drawn there
and if you're following it because you
think a good person would be drawn there
leave that space for the good people who
are naturally drawn there
yes David yes so okay let's wrap up I
want to see if you have any change in
how you feel about the question of what
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world
what I think is the most beautiful thing
in the world what do I think is the most
beautiful thing in the whole do you mean
she would even by changing the question
because I think I asked you at last time
oh I'm curious what I am don't tell me
what I answered the seal answer it new
cuz I can put fresh yeah fresh from a
couple months now
infinite potential is what's coming to
me
I love it and why
I get this feeling of awe around it and
humility like the pleasant kind of
humility we were like oh my god I'm just
nothing in this great mystery it feels
really good to be nothing and with that
this feeling of well I'm also part of
this great mystery that's what comes to
me beautiful and can I can I wrap by
saying I'm really needing support right
now if you're moved by what I'm up to in
this world I would love your help with
this play it's how I'm feeling called to
express what's going through me right
now and it's the first step on a longer
series of outputs around what it is to
be an empath and helping people come
into their own experience of subtle
realms so if that moves you please go to
my website empath dot NYC and find my
Kickstarter through there click on
Ellen's link to the Kickstarter I really
appreciate it please support artists
creators builders people that are
manifesting their soul blueprints into
the world like that support them support
us we need your help
and together we will build a beautiful
future David thank you a little much for
coming pleasure
to be here this this was so much fun
this is so much fun Ron said the
producing and directing huge thank you
everyone it was a comment below let us
know your thoughts we would love to hear
from you let us know your feels we'd
love to hear from you also go and create
go and build go manifest your destiny
into the world
go do it go execute and support David
support the play that's coming in New
York City November 29 got it through
December 8 December 9 just through
December 9 so go and support him much
love everyone thank you and we will see
you soon